was sich beobachten konnte war zumindest
die ankunft der beiden dürften hier
zuerst markus söder überpünktlich als
gastgeber um 10.40 also genau 20 minuten
vor abfahrt war er dann hier um die
kanzlerin in empfang zu nehmen die auch
etwas über pünktlich hier ankam
kurz noch ihre maske aufsetzte auf der
rückbank ihrer limousine und dann
ausstieg das war eine sehr herzliche
begrüßung kann man sagen so weit dass
unter corona bedingungen möglich ist
aber so beugte sich so als er deutete so
eine verbeugung an kann man kann sagen
er hat ihr den hof gemacht also die
beiden gehen wirklich sehr innig
miteinander um dann um punkt 11 uhr also
wirklich planmäßig alles abgelaufen der
um punkt 11 uhr sind die beiden auf den
raddampfer und dann ging es los
merkel und söder saßen dann vorne in der
sonne durften dann auch mit
sicherheitsabstand die maske abnehmen
und haben die schöne schifffahrt
sicherlich genossen
man stelle sich vor der hitze hat
geregnet bei dem termin alles soweit gut
gegangen wir sehen hier dieses erste
foto vom boot carina du sagst er hat ihr
den hof gemacht das nehmen wir mit
dieser schaltet